في ملف انتخابات التجديد النصفي للكونجرس
الامريكي اصبحت ولايه بنسلفانيا في قلب
المشهد السياسي هذا الاسبوع حيث يتوجه
اليها رؤساء امريكا في الماضي وايضا
الحاضر الديمقراطيون والجمهوريون سارعوا
لتعبئه الناخبين قبيل انتخابات التجديد
النصفي ذهب الفريقان الى حد دعوه الرئيسين
السابقين دونالد ترامب وبراك اوباما
بالاضافه الى الرئيس الحالي جوبايدر
لزياره الولايه حيث
ظهر الرؤساء الثلاثه في تجمعات انتخابيه
الرئيس الامريكي خلال تجمع للحزب
الديمقراطي ان انتخابات الولايه النصفيه
الاسبوع المقبل ستكون لحظه فارقه في مصير
الديمقراطيه قائله انه يجب ان يتحدث
الجميع بصوت واحد من جانبه دعاء الرئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب الى حشد
موجه حمراء عملاقه طبعا هنا في اشاره الى
لون حزبه من اجل ضمان الفوز على
الديمقراطيين لوقف تدمير البلاد وانقاذ
الحلم الامريكي حسب قوله